grosse parle aujourd'hui des nouveaux
écouteurs de Marshall c'est les motifs
de ce sont les motifs de ANC avec
réduction de bruit actifs nouveaux
écouteurs de Marshall qui sont super
cool alors si vous me connaissez vous
savez que j'aime Marshall et ça fait un
bon moment que je bosse avec Marshall à
venir tester différents produits
aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo qui
réalisait en partenariat avec Marshall
je vais donc aujourd'hui vous présenter
ces motifs de ANC une fois de plus
j'aime bien parce qu'on trouve vraiment
l'esprit Marshall avec le logo le nom
motif anc2 et il vous le masse surtout
très très fort ici active noise comme
selling
tout se passe ici dans cette étui petite
étui Marshall sur lequel on va venir
retrouver le branding de la marque on
retrouve sur mon ampli mon vieil ampli
Marshall mon 2700r que j'ai depuis
1995 pour vous dire que c'est une très
vieille histoire et là je vous montre le
setup chez moi c'est vraiment mon setup
de musique que je suis en train
d'agrémenter ça c'est une enceinte
Marshall dont je vous ai parlé il y a
pas longtemps c'est la gouverne 3
d'ailleurs si elle vous intéresse allez
jeter sur la chaîne je vous la présente
également autant vous dire que le son
Marshall je connais depuis que je suis
gamin j'aime ça et ça ça me plaît donc
quand je vois ce design au niveau de
cette étui je suis
superbement conquis pourquoi ben tout
simplement parce que j'aime ça et que je
trouve ça super super cool donc c'est
chouette de pouvoir retrouver l'univers
des amplis Marshall et de la musique
Marshall directement ici et d'ailleurs
fun fact je sais pas si vous le savez
mais Marshall a également label de
musique je le savais absolument pas
Marshall m'a invité c'est au mois de
mars de l'année dernière à venir à un
gros salon TEC qui s'appelle south by
SOS ouest ça se passe avec mon très bel
accent vous avez vu ça se passe à Austin
au Texas et dans lequel on a profité de
trois jours de musique complètement
dingue et j'ai pu courir justement à
cette occasion que Marshall avait un
label avec des artistes Marshall
d'ailleurs si vous êtes sur Spotify
allez jeter une oreille vous avez une
playlist avec tous les artistes à venir
découvrir voilà c'est pour moi c'est
Karlo ça fait plaisir on a vraiment ce
design de légende qu'on connaît chez
Marshall et que j'adore avec un toucher
qui fait vraiment penser à celui des
amplis Marshall même le bouton que vous
avez là ça vous fait des petits cercles
et on sent vraiment le côté matière le
logo Marshall qu'on reconnaît parmi 1000
à l'arrière vous avez le nom du produit
avec quelques mentions obligatoires
notamment la mention CE votre charge en
dessous qui se fait en usb-c et puis
lorsque vous ouvrez c'est là que la
magie opère vous avez vos écouteurs et
vous retrouver un design qui est quand
même supracool avec le logo Marshall ici
sur le pavé tactile donc ça c'est
chouette la petite partie du bas qui
fait vraiment penser un bouton d'ampli
bouton d'ampli bouton d'enceinte
Marshall il est vraiment une fois de
plus dans l'univers Marshall avec une
vraie sensation sous le doigt vous avez
vraiment ce côté matière et ça c'est
vachement chouette dessous vous avez
l'effet doré qu'on retrouve également
sur les boutons d'amplifier les boutons
d'enceintes Marshall bien évidemment on
retrouve ce côté matière ici à
l'intérieur au niveau du capteur de
présence ici le petit right right ou
left la petite connectique qui situe là
et puis vos embouts et si il faut le
savoir vous n'avez qu'un seul coloris
c'est le noir c'est le noir Marshall
bien évidemment
avoir de bons écouteurs c'est bien mais
il faut vraiment avoir du confort
lorsque vous venez les porter ça c'est
cool parce que ils viennent se
positionner très facilement dans vos
oreilles hop là vous le twistez
légèrement et là il est dans votre
oreille voyez alors là je suis pas en
train de faire un pogo et je suis pas où
elle fait c'est en train de me jeter
partout mais pour autant la tenue est
vraiment là entre élément important vous
avez différentes tailles d'embour en
fonction de la taille de vos oreilles je
vous montre ça se passe juste ici vous
allez avoir alors bien évidemment les
médiums qui sont montés par défaut que
vous avez sur vos écouteurs vous avez
également les Smalls vous avez les
larges comme ça ça conviendra à
l'anatomie de chacun à la morphologie de
chacun pour trouver votre confort on se
parle donc ici d'un trap qui sont très
confortables avec un vrai pavé tactile
qu'on va retrouver sur le côté sur le M2
Marshall juste là ça en fait c'est la
zone tactile si bien que je peux bien
totalement la configurer dans mon
application alors je vous montre
l'application dans quelques instants
mais voyez je veux lancer la musique
j'appuie une fois je veux éteindre la
musique je rappuie une fois et puis
toutes les commandes classiques qu'on
attend ici l'écouteur double tape
morceau suivant triple tape morceau
précédent on peut également venir
modifier le volume activer désactiver la
réduction de bruit mettez le mode
transparent si qui est un mode
transparent pour venir entendre ce qui
se passe autour de nous il y a également
le Spotify tape mais ça je vous montre
une fois de plus dans l'application donc
on a un vrai contrôle complet ici au
bout de votre doigt que ce soit sur
votre écouteur droit ou sur votre
écouteur gauche
puisqu'on parle de Marshall on parle
également de son signature de son de
légende alors je vous le dis le son
Marshall est plus orienté musique rock
ici par écouteur vous avez un
transducteur dynamique de 6 mm donc si
vous voulez profiter de gros rives de
guitare ACDC John jet ou compagnie et
j'en passe des meilleurs et bien pour
moi c'est totalement adapté une fois de
plus je vous montrerai vous avez des
équaliseur dans l'application on regarde
ça dans quelques instants sont des
écouteurs extrêmement efficaces je
trouve que par moment on va légèrement
de manquer de finesse sur les aigus donc
si vous vous écoutez du jazz et que vous
voulez vraiment capter tous les sons de
cymbales et de la clarté il va peut-être
falloir bien gratouiller un peu les
coaliseur au sujet extrêmement important
ici c'est la réduction de bruit Marshall
est venue améliorer sa réduction de
bruit active on a également une
meilleure gestion du bruit du vent c'est
quand même plutôt chouette autant la
réduction de bruit sauf vachement bien
parce que ça vient vous isolez lorsque
vous avez besoin lorsque vous êtes dans
un train lorsque vous êtes dans un bus
lorsque vous voulez pas entendre la télé
qui gueule à côté vous avez un petit
frère une petite sœur un compagnon une
compagne bref et qui a du bordel que
vous voulez pas non et je vous comprends
vous vous enfermez avec votre réduction
de bruit qui pour le coup vous isole
bien donc ça c'est vachement cool mais
que vous êtes en déplacement vous
marchez dans la rue que vous allez
courir vous voulez écouter de la musique
vous voulez pour autant être attentif à
ce qui se passe autour de vous notamment
au danger lorsque vous allez venir
traverser entendre une voiture bref
faire attention et bien vous avez le
mode transparency qui marche super bien
et puis vous pouvez tout désactiver
toutes électronique et ça fonctionnera
également à noter ici ça c'est plutôt
chouette que dans l'application une fois
de plus on va y venir à cette
application et bien vous pouvez venir
régler la quantité de réduction de bruit
active dans vos oreilles plus ou moins
en fonction du niveau d'attention vous
voulez sur le monde extérieur à savoir
ici que vous avez du Bluetooth 5.3 et le
avec les codec SBC AAC et LC3 on se
parle d'écouteurs qui iront aussi pour
le sport c'est pas forcément leur usage
premier mais si vous voulez aller courir
et que vous transpirez dessus ça va
aller on a des écouteurs qui sont
certifiés IPX5 et un des tuiles il fait
X4 vous évitez de me mettre de la flotte
sur votre étui mais si vous avez un peu
transpiration sur les écouteurs ça va
bien vous les rincer avec un petit
chiffon propre
il y a notre point qui a vraiment été
amélioré par rapport à la génération
précédente et bien c'est l'autonomie on
a 10 heures d'autonomie en plus vous
montez jusqu'à 30 heures d'écoute avec
le boîtier et là je vous parle avec la
réduction de bruit activé et si vous me
désactivez la réduction de bruit vous
montez jusqu'à 43 heures d'écoute tout
en sachant que vous avez 6 heures
d'écoute par écouteur avec la réduction
de bruit activée et 9 heures d'écoute
par écouteurs avec la réduction de bruit
désactivée je suis convaincu de toute
façon je vous le recommande pas qu'il
faut écouter pendant 6 heures de suite
de la musique ou pendant 30 heures de
suite de la musique mais ce qui est
rassurant derrière ça c'est que si vous
savez pendant une période vous n'allez
pas croiser de prise électrique pour
venir vous recharger et bien malgré tout
vous allez pouvoir profiter de votre
musique sur une longue période et ça
c'est vraiment cool à noter également
qu'à l'intérieur vous allez retrouver un
câble de recharge et qui lui aussi
reprend totalement à l'école Marchal
avec ce côté matière un point qui est
super important ici c'est que bien
évidemment vous pouvez venir le
recharger vous avez de l'usb-c en
dessous vous le recharger très
facilement donc là c'est extrêmement
rassurant mais vous avez également de la
charge sans fil donc si vous avez
l'habitude de venir recharger votre
smartphone sans fil vous pouvez
également poser dessus vos écouteurs qui
se rechargeront et ça c'est bien et puis
vous avez aussi de la charge rapide pour
finir attention ici vous leur chargez 15
minutes et vous profitez d'une heure de
musique
5 kg c'est très précis ce que je vous
recommande très honnêtement c'est de
laisser le son Marshall parce que c'est
vraiment ce qu'on vient rechercher quand
on veut écouter de la musique rock alors
il y a pas que de la musique rock on
peut venir écouter ici mais pour moi
c'est totalement optimisé pour la
musique rock vous venez ensuite
paramétrer vos commandes tactile ici
très facilement alors vous choisissez
standard le minimum ou alors vous
désactivez carrément tout et là vous
avez Lecture pause on appuie une fois
avancer on appuie deux fois ça permet de
répondre accrocher un appel retour
morceau précédent on appuie trois fois
le Spotify tape on appuie une fois on
appuie on laisse le doigt appuyer et
ensuite vous avez les actions
personnalisées vous laissez votre doigt
appuyer et vous venez les choisir ça
c'est cool oreillette gauche par exemple
moi j'ai mis le contrôle du bruit mais
je pourrais également mettre
l'équaliseur bien changer l'équaliseur
le volume l'assistant vocal par défaut
ou alors ne rien faire et pour contrôle
du bruit je peux choisir de mettre la
réduction de proactive les modes
transparence et puis même carrément le
désactiver des fois lorsque je vais
couper toute l'électronique et
exactement la même chose sur l'oreille
droite à savoir que si vous choisissez
le volume vous choisissez soit de monter
le volume soit de le baisser soyons vous
dire ici sur un appui long je monte le
volume ici sur un appui long je baisse
le volume à vous de voir ça c'est
vachement bien parce que c'est vous qui
avez la main là dessus après il y a
quelques petites options en plus le son
d'interaction activer ou désactiver les
habits audio de notif de ITC lecture
pose automatique parce que vous mettez
aux écouteurs et que vous les enlever
préserver les batteries prolonger la
durée de vie des batteries alors vous
choisissez la préservation ou alors pas
du tout voyez en fonction de là vous
allez mettre le curseur ça va jouer sur
la limite de température on va jouer
également sur la limite de recherche
avec une capacité maximale à 90% et puis
la vitesse de recharge par défaut
autre sujet sur lequel Marshall est venu
travailler c'est la durabilité avec une
batterie que Marshall nous annonce plus
durable et un travail qui a été fait
également au niveau de l'étui et des
oreillettes avec 70% de plastique
recyclés à partir d'appareils
électroniques usagés mais également de
bouteilles d'eau et de feu automobile
les motifs de ANC Marshall sont
disponibles au tarif de 199 €. donc si
vous voulez retrouver le son de légende
le design iconique profitez dans son
tranchant lorsque vous allez venir
écouter des guitares et bien vous pouvez
aller sur les Marshall motifs 2 ANC une
fois de plus je suis très fan du design
faut que sont des écouteurs qui sont
efficaces qui fonctionnent bien le
tactile est cool l'application est bien
faite on en a pour son argent donc si
vous recherchez des écouteurs avec un
design intemporel rock n' roll avec des
écouteurs qui sont aussi super jolis et
bien vous pouvez sur ces écouteurs de
Marshall les motifs de AMC que
personnellement j'aime bien que je
trouve cool voilà si vous intéresse bien
évidemment et bien je vous mets un lien
juste en bas dans la description et une
fois de plus cette enceinte wubborn 3
vous fait de l'oeil et bien j'en ai fait
une vidéo elle est quelque part par là
allez jeter un œil vous m'en direz des
nouvelles